this morning president trump faces
pushback from his own party for refusing
to say that he will leave
office peacefully if he is defeated in
november
the republican-led senate unanimously
passed a resolution reaffirming its
commitment to a peaceful transition
as ben tracy reports the president
continues to attack the election process
itself
along with his opponent we love hispanic
americans
at a rally in florida last night there
were few masks but plenty of attacks on
the president's opponent
joe biden elitist when you put out word
you're not going to be campaigning today
so he does the lid all the time i'm
working my ass off with new polls
showing president trump trailing biden
in several swing states
he again suggested he might not accept
the outcome of the election
we want to make sure the election is
honest and i'm not sure that it can be i
don't
i don't know that it can be even though
vice president mike pence insisted in
wisconsin they would
on one condition we will accept free and
fair election results a day earlier the
president would not commit to a peaceful
transfer of power
we're going to have to see what happens
you know that president trump
you are not a dictator on thursday
democrats and several republican leaders
put the president on notice look we've
had an orderly transfer of power
every four years since washington
was selected for a second term in 1792
that will happen again to the winner of
the november 3rd election
the president who was loudly booed at
the supreme court as he paid his
respects the late justice ruth bader
ginsburg
continues to claim mail-in ballots lead
to widespread fraud
but his own fbi director testified on
capitol hill
saying that's simply not true we have
not
seen historically any kind of
coordinated national
voter fraud effort in a major election
whether it's by mail or otherwise i will
never let the radical left take away
your health care
in north carolina thursday the president
unveiled what he calls his vision for
health care
but it's really an executive order
directing congress to pass legislation
to deal with surprise medical billing it
also makes protecting pre-existing
conditions
official u.s policy this is a firm
signed and done
so we can put that to rest but that was
actually put to rest ten years ago by
president obama when he signed the
affordable care act which made covering
pre-existing conditions u.s law
president trump's order on medical bills
also does not carry any legal weight
unless congress fails to pass
legislation
in that case it directs hhs to issue a
regulation
anthony ben thank you